alanis morissette is slamming director
alison clayman's documentary jagged
which is based on the singer's life and
just had its world premiere at the 2021
toronto international film festival uh
yeah now originally atlantis agreed to
participate in the documentary about the
celebration of jagged's 25th anniversary
but just hours before the premiere
alanis criticized the film as reductive
and salacious telling variety quotes
i was lulled into a false sense of
security and their salacious agenda
became apparent immediately upon my
seeing the first cut of the film this is
when i knew our visions were in fact
painfully diverged this was not the
story i agreed to tell yeah the singer
added that she will not attend any event
supporting the movie saying this
i sit here now experiencing the full
impact of having trusted someone who did
not warrant being trusted i've chosen
not to attend any event around this
movie for two reasons one is that i am
on tour right now the other is that not
unlike many stories and unauthorized
biographies out there over the years
this one includes implications and facts
that are simply not true
yeah so et canada has reached out to the
director for comment on alanis's
statement but speaking with deadline at
their tiff studio in toronto allison
spoke about the fact alanis might not
attend the premiere saying this of
course it would have been great if she
could be here with us but i'm so
grateful for all the time that she did
put into making this film uh yeah and
among aspects of the film alanis claims
on camera that multiple men engaged in
underage sex with her when she was just
15 years old and recently speaking with
the washington post alaina said that it
took years in therapy to admit there had
been any kind of victimization on her
part explaining to them i would always
say i was consenting and then i'd be
reminded hey you were 15 you're not
consenting at 15. now i'm like oh yeah
they're all pedophiles it's all
statutory rape
the alleged abusers are not named but it
is assumed the abuse took place in
canada during her early years of
fame this is sad this makes me sad yeah
uh geez the
the tough part with all of this is that
she says
so much of it was wrong i know but she
doesn't say which parts were wrong and
when you're dealing with
um you know when you're dealing with
sexual assault and statutory rape i
think you need to be clear on what if
you're disputing something especially if
it's your own words or the way that your
words were you feel were manipulated or
used out of context i think you need to
be i think you need to be specific um
but when it comes to documentaries you
know this is one of those interesting
show business things where yes it is
atlanta's story but it's not her movie
yeah it's somebody else's movie and
oftentimes you see this where somebody
sits down and you get very comfortable
in those situations you start spending a
lot of time and you see this with more
with articles not so much documentaries
but you see this when these reporters
sit with somebody for weeks and they do
these long profiles and they become very
comfortable with them and you say things
that maybe you didn't think you were
going to say going into it and then when
you see it it's all on tape and it's all
you and it's your words and maybe
they're not true but maybe she didn't
want to say them or say them in that way
but it's it's unfortunate because i was
actually quite looking forward to
watching the documentary and now i don't
know if i will because i think that i'm
going to kind of feel dirty watching it
knowing alanis feels so gross about it
well man i don't know what this is about
me and my character but i want to watch
this even more now because i you know
atlanta's more set for me like so many
people my age she was in everything like
everything i named the cassette off by
heart i did music videos of my
girlfriends to ironic we filmed it it
was my life so i was very very excited
about this um listen
if you're going to talk about
abuse that happened to you when you're
younger and now it's going to be in a
documentary you can only imagine she's
now going okay this will be asked of me
in every interview i do going forward
articles are being written about this
you know she has said she was she was in
a dark time in her her life when she
talked about this people have different
perspectives on things you know when
when they're out of a place like that so
i just feel bad that she
doesn't feel comfortable with something
that should be so celebrated about her
life
um but i also i also feel for the
director she's making a movie sure you
know it's a documentary and
it's her movie it's yeah it's her movie
to make but it's just the fact that now
we're left thinking well maybe there's
parts of this that aren't true yeah and
that's the hard part and that's the hard
part for alanis and that's the hard part
for the director because now the
question is well what is real and what
is not it i know so addy's saying well
if it wasn't what she agreed to i can't
blame her for not wanting
anything to do with it and it could this
could be something as simple as they sit
down and they have a conversation and
elena starts talking and it becomes very
therapeutic and i'm not saying this is
what happened so easy it happens it
becomes very therapeutic and you realize
that you're going down this path right
and you sort of feel good about it you
feel good about all the things that
you're saying it's a sort of safe space
to do it and then you get to the end and
you go oh god but like we can't use any
of that right but then whose decision
does that become like
who's who makes that call afterwards
yeah and that's where things like this
start to you know fall apart yeah
nelson's saying i'm with roz um
so yeah i just i feel like i'm sure
you've been here too like i don't even
like going to work parties when you like
overshare things and after you're like
oh i and now this is in a documentary